♫ No, woman, no cry ♫
♫ 'ere, little darlin'
Don't shed no tears ♫
♫ No, woman, no cry ♫
♫ Good friends we have
and good friends we've lost ♫
♫ Along the way ♫
♫ In this great future
You can't forget your past ♫
♫ So dry your tears I say ♫
♫ Everything's gonna be alright, now
Everything's gonna be alright, now ♫
♫ Everything's gonna be alright, now ♫
♫ Everything's gonna be alright
Everything's gonna be alright ♫
♫ Everything's gonna be alright, now
♫ Everything's gonna be alright
Everything's gonna be alright ♫
RAMONDA
I am Queen of the most powerful nation
in the world,
and my entire family is gone.
Have I not given everything?
♫ Everything's gonna be alright
(We gon' be alright) ♫
♫ We gon' be alright, do you hear me
Do you feel me, we gon' be alright ♫
♫ We gon' be alright
We gon' be alright ♫
♫ Do you hear me, do you feel me
Do you hear me, do you feel me ♫
We gon' be alright ♫
♫ Uh, and when I wake up ♫
♪♪